um in all that crowd of humanity outside
kabul airport um amongst them desperate
people trying to get back to the uk a
number of them british passport holders
and today that confirmation from the
foreign secretary that yes two british
male adults um were among those killed
and the child of a third british family
i'm told in total there are four
families four british families who've
suffered from this
three fatalities in three separate
families and then another individual was
injured a british national and that
person was brought onto the airfield
treated by medics and has either been
evacuated back to the uk or is going to
be evacuated to the uk and then there is
another another child victim who was
injured and this child is belongs to the
family of one of the three fatalities
and that child i understand is being
treated at a hospital in kabul so yes
yesterday we we had the news that
horrible awful death toll
of afghans killed
of us marines and a navy medic killed
and today the confirmation that british
nationals have also died in this attack
and like you said the foreign secretary
released a statement in which he talked
about his deep sadness at this news he
said that yesterday's despicable act
sorry yesterday's despicable attack
underlines the dangers facing those in
afghanistan and reinforces why we are
doing all we can to take people out
we're offering consular support to their
families and we don't turn our back on
those who look to us in their hour of
need and we will never be cowed by
terrorists although there are plenty of
of people in afghanistan right now who
really believe the uk has turned its
back on them they're people like former
afghan interpreters who have been trying
to get onto these evacuation flights at
the timeline for getting onto those
flights has is is quickly reaching its
conclusion and they are there are going
to be many hundreds left behind um so a
really tragic situation and
yes further news of um of the impact on
on on british nationals too